[CHEERING]
[MUSIC - DAVI, "THAT THUMP"]
DAVI: Google.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Google.
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
DAVI: Google.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Google.
DAVI: My name is Davi.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Davi.
DAVI: I come from somewhere
up there and out there,
but shh, that was a secret.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Secret.
DAVI: This is an invitation.
FEMALE SPEAKER: An invitation.
DAVI: For us to explore
who we are and who we be.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Be.
DAVI: Will you join us?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
Whoo!
DAVI: Will you join us?
All right.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING]
[MUSIC DAVI, "I CAN SEE YOU
CLEAR"]
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING]
DAVI: Ernest Baker, everybody.
[MUSIC DAVI, "WONDER ON A LUMP"]
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - DAVI, "REPTIIIIIILE"]
AUDIENCE: Yay.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, yeah?
[DRUM]
DAVI: Ernest Baker, everybody.
[CHEERING]
DAVI: All right.
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
Yes!
[MUSIC - DAVI, "GREAT BEYOND]
DAVI: Speed it up.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LOREN: Davi, I'd like you
to tell me more about, if you
had to, in a nutshell,
tell me about your music
and what you want to get
across, what would it be?
DAVI: My music is
just an illustration
of some of the things
that are important to me
within the society, within
my heart, within my vision.
And the best vessel that I
found is to do it through music.
So music I see through my
body and through my voice.
And then directing folks on
instruments that I don't play.
So if someone asked
me, what genre--
I get that a lot--
my music is, it's
somewhere between new wave,
electronica, and soul.
I used to call it
Afro-electro funk,
but I'm actually
moving beyond that
at this point in
my musical journey.
And I think at the
very core of it,
I'm always pushing something
I call human [INAUDIBLE].
It's something I created
when I was at NYU.
And essentially,
it's using things
that identify one's
uniqueness-- whatever
makes them special,
whatever makes them tick,
whatever makes their skin
crawl, those things that
really make them who they are.
And once people are able to
understand that for themselves,
then they'll be
able to recognize
that in another
person, and appreciate
that for another person,
and love another person
because that person has that
beyond any color, prejudice,
and bias that they may
have against another.
If we can begin to understand
ourselves as universal beings,
then I think we'll
be on a good track.
RYAN LOREN: You do a
lot of other things too.
You choreograph.
You're a DJ.
So tell me what experience
you have in those worlds
and how it convergenced
into music now.
DAVI: So choreography
was something
that was really easy for
me when I was growing up.
At NYU, I was a step
master of the step team.
We were number one.
My best friend's in the
audience, [? Taja. ?]
And we were chumping it up.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
DAVI: And we were number one
in the Northeast at one time.
And then I started doing
that for other schools.
In the meantime, I
started getting mentored
by a modern choreographer,
Kathryn Posin, who took me
under her wing in the middle
of my junior year at NYU.
And she said, you're
a choreographer.
Not just for step, but
you're a choreographer
in all these other ways too.
So explore that.
And she pushed me to
so many other things
I wasn't actually prepared for.
I ended up choreographing for
Kerry Washington, and David
Alan Grier, and
Tyler James Williams,
and a whole bunch of
folks for this movie
called, "We The Peeples."
And it came out last year.
And in the meantime, I
also worked with a group
called Cubic Zirconia, doing
all their tour choreography
and video choreography.
I'm in two of their videos,
if you want to check them out,
and also doing choreography
for this other group
called Telephone.
So I've done a lot of different
choreography for other people.
And it's been really, really
exciting doing and illustrating
what movement looks like
for me in my own songs.
Because I don't
know if you noticed,
but my movement is not
hip hop and modern.
It's somewhere in between,
somewhere in the grays.
And I think that
that's really exciting.
I'm excited about it.
RYAN LOREN: Where are you
going to take it next?
What can we expect from you?
DAVI: Well, I think the
path that I've been on
has always been around music.
It just so happened that it
came out through movement
initially on a public eye.
But it's always been something.
My mother's here,
and I always told her
I wanted to be an artist.
I created my life
plan when I was 16,
and that was the
forefront of what
I was going to be
doing with my life.
So it was always about music.
I think what worked
at the time is
why I did choreography
first on a public level.
But I was also recording my
music during that time too.
Actually, the first EP
was done at the same time
that I was filming,
"We the Peeples."
I was staying at a
friend's spot in New York,
and I was going back and forth
from Stanford, Connecticut.
And when I came back,
I was recording.
When I was in Stanford,
I was filming.
So it was a really
exciting time period.
So it's always
been around music.
And the next steps for me
is just really expanding
what this Davi universe is.
I think when people
come to my shows,
they're always explaining,
as an experience.
And that's really what I want
people to get involved in,
a new world, a new culture that
not only excites you musically,
but also excites you to shift
things in your own life.
That's actually what
"That Thump" talks about.
A lot of people don't know that.
That was me introducing
myself and challenging
you to expand the
ways in understanding
how artists can impact you.
Because I remember,
for example, when
I started listening
to Erykah Badu.
My whole [INAUDIBLE] changed.
I walked differently.
I looked at people differently.
I was like, I'm a
whole person who's
been impacted by Erykah Badu.
And that happened in small ways
with Prince, Santigold, MIA,
Michael Jackson-- a
whole bunch of people
who have impacted me,
and just beginning
to take notice of how artists
impact the way we think,
and how we feel about ourselves.
RYAN LOREN: You
have a unique sound,
and I hope you keep bringing it.
DAVI: You don't have to hope.
RYAN LOREN: Oh, I know
you will, and I really
appreciate you being here.
So thank you so much.
DAVI: Absolutely.
Thank you for this platform.
RYAN LOREN: Everybody,
give a hand to Davi.
Thank you, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Whoo!